mais messieurs bonsoir depuis quelques
heures les écoliers français sont en
vacances et dans quelques heures demain
ou après demain à leurs parents le sont
aussi ou en tout cas se trouveront bien
une fois ou deux fois de trois jours de
repos pour affronter les fêtes de fin
d'année et donc être très nombreux à
vous lancer sur les routes
je vous rappelle en conséquence les
conseils du ministère de l'équipement en
pareille occasion éviter au départ des
grandes villes le vendredi soir et le
samedi matin
les possibilités de départ dans de
bonnes conditions sont assez réduites
parce que s'ajoutent à cela des routes
assez difficile il a beaucoup neigé
aujourd'hui sur une grande partie de la
france et le verglas a fait sa
réapparition en de nombreux endroits
alors tout de suite laurent broomhead la
question est ce que cela va continuer à
écouter pour les météorologistes
français c'est la dépression non pas
d'un point de vue moral mais bel et bien
physique en effet au dessus de la france
il ya comme un cru une cuvette de
laquelle la pression de l'air est
inférieur à l'habitude et comme dans
tout les couverts et bien la fois l'eau
s'engouffre alors concrètement pour
faire grève ça veut dire quoi le temps
sera plutôt mille alors d'abord demain
vendredi sur le quart sud est beaucoup
de pluie avec de la neige au dessus de
800 mille mètres d'altitude
des orages sur le midi méditerranéen et
la corse et des vents et la pluie
tombait et des petits vents d'est assez
fort en mer sur le littoral sur le reste
du pays
eh bien ma foi un temps médiocre avec
des averses de pluie ou de neige
et puis tout de même de belles
éclaircies sur l'ouest et le sud-ouest
les températures seront un peu moins
forte qu'aujourd'hui mais il faut
craindre tout de même quelques jolis
dans l'intérieur du pays
c'est pour samedi et dimanche tout temps
ça c'était pour vendredi et maintenant
pour samedi ça m'intéresse voilà deux
jours seulement samedi vient un soleil
que je place près du golfe du lion les
faits eh bien il fera meilleur je retire
la pluie le vent cette fois attendra au
nord les nuages sont iront vers l'est
cela reste du pays des brouillards
givrants le matin c'est pourquoi il
faudra se méfier pour les automobilistes
et puis tout de même de températures un
peu plus fraîche mais dans la journée
une nouvelle vague de pluie arrivera à
près de l'atlantique je prends place des
nuages ici là bas quand même site
scénario arrive voilà et ceux qui nous
annonce donc à nouveau de l'appui sur la
moitié sud du pays pour les jours
suivants i
ces langues jour proche souvent de ne
pas nous donner prévisions
terme ne pas vous engager davantage et
bien dans six mois ça va peut-être
changer car vous aurez à votre
disposition cet ordinateur que viennent
d'installer en grande bretagne 17 pays
râpé regardez bien
jusqu'à présent les scientifiques ne
savent prévoir le temps à coup sûr que
pour les deux ou trois jours à venir et
uniquement pour notre hémisphère nord
mais tout peut changer ici dans la
banlieue de londres a wedding où la
communauté européenne vient d'installer
craie le plus puissant ordinateur du
monde dès juillet 1979
il devrait fournir chaque jour une
prévision du temps pour six jours
puis 10 enfin deux semaines à l'avance
une véritable révolution avec ses
circuits électroniques
c'est une vision globale qui donnera de
l'évolution du temps pour toute la
planète
chaque jour il recevra du monde entier
plus d'un million et demi d'informations
données par des ballons bateaux avions
et autres satellites et qui alimenteront
une fausse atmosphère terrestre fait
d'équations mathématiques compliqué
représentant les tourbillons les nuages
les températures la pluie la neige
pendant six heures très effectuera
quelques 1000 milliards d'opérations
pour réaliser son voyage de dix jours
dans l'avenir de notre planète
une exploration raconté ensuite au
météorologiste de tous les pays mais par
manque de stations de mesure à la
surface de la terre
il semble pour l'instant impossible aux
spécialistes d'imaginer prévoir le temps
pour plus de 15 jours
comment expliquez vous que certains
faits d et en un mois à l'avancé ou plus
à ce moment-là ne s'agit pas du tout de
méthode
telle que celle que nous utilisons ici
mais de méthodes statistiques et sur
lesquels les
froment scientifiques sont très doute le
point de vue dans le jargon vision
déterministe que nous avons adoptée ici
reposent sur des lois de la physique
bien connu alors que les choses dit
statistique repose sur des observations
uniquement et depuis une période de
temps relativement court 100 ans
là point de vue statistique n'est
attendue ce qui fait que les résultats
qui peuvent en être tirés sont très
suspect 60 millions de francs par an
dont 18% pour la france c'est le prix du
sérieux mais les bénéfices économiques
de ces prévisions rapporterait
estime-t-on 25 fois plus le succès
pourraient alors se chiffrer en
milliards de francs
la vie sociale maintenant d'abord il
faut savoir qu'à l'edf la situation
devenue normale après deux jours de
jours donc a fait la grande panne ds
jure qu'elle est en mesure maintenant de
faire face à toutes les éventualités
savoir aussi que chez renault véhicules
industriels 950 emplois seront supprimés
dans l'année à venir
savoir enfin que les ouvriers d'usinor
longwy ont empêché ce matin la réunion
du comité d'établissement et que ceux de
denain se préparent à une journée ville
morte demain c'est pour toutes ces
raisons et aussi pour protester contre
les augmentations de cotisations de
sécurité sociale que la cgt à l'échelon
national cette fois avait organisé
aujourd'hui une journée d'action marquée
surtout par des manifestations sur tout
le territoire
et puis par des débrayages sensible
essentiellement dans la presse puisque
un quotidien sur cinq seulement apparu
aujourd'hui à paris un cortège de la
bastille au palais royal georges séguy
en tête a réuni plusieurs milliers de
manifestants
cette journée nationale d'action n'a pas
provoqué de sérieuses perturbations sauf
dans la presse ou peu de journaux ont
paru aujourd'hui
pour le reste pas de coupures
d'électricité après la panne de mardi
les trains de banlieue étaient réduits
dans deux gares paris
seulement le trafic grandes lignes étant
normes pour la cgt le bilan est positif
à la veille des fêtes de fin d'année à
saint nazaire plus de dix mille
personnes ont manifesté ce matin pour
protester contre l'intervention de la
police à l'hôtel de ville hier soir
intervention destinée à libérer trois
directeurs des chantiers d'alstom
atlantique retenu par des ouvriers c'est
à l'issue d'un meeting organisé pour
réclamer le paiement des heures d'arrêt
de travail dues à la panne d'électricité
de mardi que le directeur avait été
séquestré à la mairie selon les
syndicats les partis de gauche
la police a agi avec brutalité molestant
même des élus de la loire atlantique la
politique maintenant avec d'abord les
sud de la réunion d'hier au parti
socialiste un commentaire de pierre
mauroy ce matin sur france inter il y a
eu un accord avec monsieur mitterrand
sur la procédure mais pas sur le fond le
député maire de lille se cherche
toujours à parvenir à une synthèse entre
les différents courants de l'actuelle
majorité au parti socialiste il ya donc
tous les socialistes sauf le crs le crs
qui annonce avoir reçu les ja la
signature de 600 responsables qui
soutiendront donc sa motion au congrès
d'avril les suit aussi de la faire alain
peyrefitte sanctionné par le rpr
aujourd'hui les dix ministres de ce
mouvement ont exprimé leur soutien au
garde des sceaux ont regretté
profondément je cite la procédure
exceptionnelle engagées contre lui et
ont demandé que tout soit fait pour
préserver l'unité du rpr communiqué donc
signé par tous les ministres rpr du
gouvernement et puis pendant ce temps à
l'assemblée le premier jour de la
session extraordinaire consacrée à la
réforme de l'indemnisation du chômage
c'est à dire en premier lieu des fameux
90%
l'allocation spéciale c'est à dire les
fameux 90% pour cause de licenciement
économique qui concerne 174 mille
chômeurs
écoute 6 milliards par an deviendrait
dégressive et diminuerait de trois mois
en trois mois pour inciter à la reprise
du travail
ceci pour le principe car les modalités
techniques d'application seront
discutées entre patronat et syndicats
l'allocation de base
elle serait versée quels que soient les
motifs de licenciement aujourd'hui 330
mille chômeurs perçoivent 40% de leur
ancien salaire puis 35 % son taux serait
relevé est également fixé par les
partenaires sociaux
les autres indemnités c'est à dire la
pré-retraite et l'allocation forfaitaire
de premier emploi ne seront pas modifiés
en cas de déficit le financement serait
comblé aux deux tiers par les employeurs
et les salariés
le tiers restant par l'état au palais
bourbon un certain nombre de députés de
l'opposition ont reproché au ministre
robert boulin d'être venu au secours du
patronat qui n'avait pu signer avec les
syndicats ces textes là important et
puis une partie des députés de la
majorité et lui ont demandé de ne pas
supprimer les 90% dans les régions en
crise et pour en finir avec cette
actualité politique je dois vous dire
que la commission des sondages qui avait
été saisie par le député charles hernu a
tenu après enquête a estimé que le
fameux sondage soler qui donnait michel
rocard largement en tête devant françois
mitterrand quant à une éventuelle
candidature aux futures présidentielles
et bien que ce sondage n'avait pas
respecté toutes les règles de forme
prescrite par la loi
deuxième journée du voyage de valéry
giscard d'estaing en guinée nos envoyés
spéciaux parlé d' enthousiasme hier et
dès aujourd'hui par de délire
la population semble avoir réservé un
accueil historique au président français
le président guinéen sékou touré a
renouvelé plusieurs fois son amitié pour
la france et son peuple et le chef de
l'état lui a répondu dans un discours
sur un stade que la confiance ne se
limite pas nous avons
les autres la réconciliation nous
pouvons démarrer maintenant la cotation
la france a précisé valérie giscard
d'estaing respectera l'indépendance de
la guinée et ses choix politiques qu'il
soit monsieur sékou touré pour ses pairs
a expliqué que la guinée socialistes
s'étaient attachés jusqu'à présent
affamés les aime et qu'elle passait
maintenant à l'étape du développement
pour développer ses richesses minières
et agricoles considérable elle demande
l'aide des pays occidentaux c'est le
revirement et en particulier l'aide de
la france main dans la main les deux
présidents ont pris un bain de foule et
saluer des milliers de guinéens venus de
toute la région
quand ce deuxième ville de la guinée
capitale de la savane
là le président sékou touré a réservé à
sono un accueil spectaculaire comme
s'ils avaient voulu dépasser le stade un
peu emprunté des retrouvailles pour
celui de la séduction
il faut dire que kankan est sans doute
un symbole de ce que peut être la future
coopération entre les deux pays
voici une région essentiellement
agricole riz maïs arachide dans laquelle
on tente d'implanter l'industrie
agroalimentaire des progrès une manche
peut-être accompli
tu es bien montrer la disponibilité de
la guinée toutes les forces vives de la
région ont défilé devant les deux
présidents des écoliers aux boulangers
des footballeurs aux agriculteurs cette
amitié naissante entre la guinée et la
france monsieur giscard d'estaing la
replacer ce soir dans le cadre plus
vaste du dialogue euro africain il a
invité le président guinéen à se joindre
à lui pour la réussite d'une telle
entreprise jugé évidente dans les
mouvances du monde actuel valéry giscard
d'estaing qui a l'intention de
poursuivre avec ou sans cravate son
séjour en afrique par un voyage celui là
privé au gabon
c'est là qu'ils ne passera les fêtes de
noël il se rendrait ensuite dans l'
empire centrafricain et regagnant à leur
parti
jimmy carter est malade il a annulé tous
ses rendez-vous aujourd'hui il souffre
d'une crise aiguë d'hémorroïdes et
passera lui c'est les fêtes de noël dans
son village natal de plaine sans géorgie
proche-orient pas de paix séparée avec
israël réaffirme solennellement monsieur
sadate les propositions égyptiennes sont
totalement inacceptable répond en écho
bot sheva gagnent et ceci à 48 heures de
la rencontre qui doit avoir lieu à
bruxelles entre égyptiens israël
et puis pendant ce temps des accrochages
sont poursuivies sur la frontière du sud
liban entre israéliens et palestiniens
fusillade en irlande du nord trois
soldats britanniques ont été tués ce
matin
et puis détournement d'avion aux états
unis entre saint-louis du missouri et
kansas city
la femme pirate de l'air aurait sur elle
des bâtons de dynamite
dès que j'en sais puisse bien sûr je
vous dis encore et puis en europe
les suites du différend franco allemand
qui a empêché un accord à bruxelles sur
les prix agricoles les allemands
accusent aujourd'hui les français de
compromettre ainsi le démarrage du
système monétaire européen
michel meyer la presse ouest allemande
évoque cet échec de bruxelles en termes
très technique et il en va de même dans
les milieux gouvernementaux
c'est là un signe de gênes et de
prudence à vrai dire bonne ne
s'attendait pas à ce que paris prenne
aussi à coeur cette question de
correction monétaires agricoles
la réaction française inquiète donc en
ce moment à bonn malgré le fait que
personne ici ne croit que le système
monétaire européen
cet enfant de valéry giscard d'estaing
et de helmut schmidt puisse être
remis en cause par cet échec agricole de
bruxelles de toute façon une position de
repli sa mort c'est déjà un contact
téléphonique direct pourrait avoir lieu
d'ici peu entre le président français et
le chancelier schmidt en vue de relancer
une rencontre entre ministres des
finances et ministre de l'agriculture de
façon à régler ce différend avant la fin
de l'année on devine est une ébauche de
sourires sur les visages d'andré gromyko
et de ça aux fans ce matin à genève
c'est assez montrait le climat favorable
qui régnait lors de la reprise des
travaux sur les discussions salt sol ce
sont les initiales pour stratégique arms
limitation frétille tant du côté avec
quelques secondes et y con on entrevoit
donc le bout du tunnel
la conclusion de 10 en discussion pour
essayer donc de limiter les armements
stratégiques
à tel point qu'en cas de succès leonid
brejnev se rendrait aux états unis à la
mi janvier
alors pourquoi cette soudaine bien parce
que les deux grands sont aperçus que la
course aux armements nucléaires en
talent est une escalade ruineux un
premier traité salt a été signé en 1972
complété en 73 et 74
le traité salt numéro 2 discuté depuis
cette époque et d'essentiellement du
même ordre il tend à imposer un nouveau
plafond au missile de toutes sortes
missiles antimissiles by abm missiles à
têtes multiples apps les meilleurs avec
cette fois ci une complication les armes
nouvelles nées depuis 1972 n'a coûté le
bombardier soviétique que les américains
ont baptisé back fait un retour de
flamme il ressemble à bombardier
américaine b un plomb voit ici un bon
banquier dont la fabrication a été
interrompue
théoriquement le bac fait un peu partant
du territoire soviétique allait jeter
sur les états unis les bomb a tenu dont
les américains il faut le compter parmi
les armes stratégiques dont le nombre
doit être limité
premier point en litige de l'autre côté
le missile américain trousses missiles
de croisière c'est une sorte d'avion
lancé un autre avion ou que l'on autre
modèle d'un sous-marin en plongée d'un
bâtiment surface
il incite à terre selon la portée du
cruise
ils devraient ou non faire partie des
lanceurs stratégique auquel un numerus
clausus et s'impose troisième difficulté
le contrôle de l'application du futur
accord un troll rendue plus difficile
par de nouveaux progrès de la technique
s'ils vendent ses gonds mikko arrive pas
à aplanir ces difficultés carter et
brejnev pourraient se rencontrer et
signer le salt 2 si l'on veut ce traité
entre en vigueur
il faudrait que cette rencontre ait lieu
bientôt car pour le ratifier
le sénat des états unis prendra son
temps presse un an pense-t-on et dès la
fin de 1979
les états unis seront en fièvre
électorale climat peu propice à
l'approbation d'accords qui par
définition demande des sacrifices
mutuelle espagne accident dramatique ce
matin une collision entre un bus de
ramassage scolaire et un train de fret
salamanque 20 à 25 enfants retrouvés la
mort on parle d'une soixantaine de
blessés
80 enfants en effet se trouvaient à bord
du bus attentat ce matin à anglet dans
les pyrénées-atlantiques contre un
militant séparatiste basque
la victime n'a pas survécu l'attentât
pour l'instant été revendiqué par une
organisation jusqu'alors inconnu l'eau à
z
et puis un trafic de faux billets
seraient à l'origine de la tuerie du bar
du téléphone à marseille le massacre au
début du mois d'octobre avaient fait dix
morts dans ce bar qui aurait servi en
unités de dépôt donc pour les
trafiquants et puis aussi la synagogue
de drancy entièrement détruite la nuit
dernière par un incendie très
vraisemblement d'origine criminelle en
une heure seulement
le bâtiment a ravagé les deux étages du
du feu par un acte criminel ou accident
c'est tout ce qu'il reste en tout cas du
temple de la communauté juive de drancy
après l' incendie qui a éclaté un peu
avant 3h ce matin
pas de victimes
le trail du d'inscriptions antisémites
mais pour le rabbin fixe l'air une nuit
qui a ravivé beaucoup de mauvais
souvenirs quand je suis arrivé ici je
peux pas vous expliquer c'était des
flammes énormes ou suis apte à moi je
dis tout de suite que c'est un acte
criminel et on nous appelait si la
deuxième fois qu'il m'arrive
il était dans la gazzetta dello fin de
mes efforts sur l'ancien déporté et là
ça m'arrivera plus chacun d'eux un
devoir de la communauté crawford
pendant la guerre le drancy et est un
centre de transit vers les camps de
concentration et aujourd'hui l'émotion
est grande parce que l' incendie reste
inexpliqué pour la police rien pour
l'instant ni les témoignages ni
l'analyse des indices ne permettent de
conclure à un acte criminel mais le mrap
mouvement contre le racisme dénonce
l'inefficacité des pouvoirs publics face
à l' escalade des exactions anti sémite
et puis cet acte a soulevé l'indignation
de représentants d'institutions juives
reçu tout à l'heure par christian bonnet
l'indignation aussi de plusieurs hommes
politiques en particulier jean pierre
bloch qui a posé une question écrite au
premier ministre l'actualité sportive et
tout d'abord le rugby la fédération
française continue à jouer les pères
fouettards la semaine dernière c'était
alain espère et bien aujourd'hui ici ou
plutôt fière 80 joueurs ont été
pénalisés cinq clubs condamnés à payer
une amende toujours le même motif
sanctions contre le jeu dur et à ce
propos m'excuse pour ce pauvre
paparemborde que j'ai fait jouer la
semaine dernière à béziers au grand dam
des palois et même des biterrois qui
aimeraient bien le voir jouer chez eux
je pense que nous allons avoir
maintenant les résultats du tiercé
l'arrivée à vincennes combinaison
gagnant dont le voyez un 4/6 les
résultats mais pas les rapports qu'ils
ne sont pas encore parvenues que nous
aurons sans doute dans notre journal de
23 ans ce qui maintenant avec le slalom
spécial masculin de la coupe du monde
qui se disputaient ce matin à kranjska
gora en yougoslavie
sous un soleil éclatant la victoire est
revenue sans grande surprise au suédois
ingemar stenmark
et puis à la 5e place et là c'est un
étonnement un français philippe hardy à
moins de trois secondes du leader
nous avons suffisamment fustigé les
français quand ça n'allait pas
pour l'heure très ces quelques couronnes
quand cela va mieux
sistema restons sur le tapis blanc
laurent broomhead l'avait prévu la
semaine dernière dans sa boule de
cristal les premières neiges sont
tombées à point pour accueillir les
quelques trois millions cinq cent mille
vacanciers de noël
mais si vous en êtes à votre premier
séjour ou si vous n'avez pas eu encore
la chance de partir la neige la chance
et les moyens propose de consulter ce
manuel du parfait skieurs un abécédaire
composé par martine laroche-joubert et
dominique merlet la circulation sur
piste de ski devient presque aussi
compliquée que la circulation sur route
et les règles de sécurité ne sont pas du
tout respecté ce qui entraîne finalement
pas mal d'accidents
alors nous vous proposons une sorte
d'almanach l'alphabet du parfait skieurs
alphabet que l'on pourrait apprendre à
l'école l'année dernière
quatre-vingt-dix-sept personnes
emportées par les avalanches
22 38 ne sortez pas imprudemment des
pistes les stations elles poursuivent
leurs efforts eh bien on a une équipe de
pisteurs qui après une chute de neige
purge cibler tous les couloirs et toutes
les parties qui peuvent être dangereux
pendant cette période là on ferme les
pistes c'est à dire ça dure en général
cette auberge qui à partir de 10h du
matin et avec des explosifs ils
déclenchent si vous voulez tout les
pulls et que ça si ce petit appel en
piste
dure sera la chute pour les citadins aux
muscles ou rouillées des comme des
inconnus au dictionnaire animal mythique
qui entraîne souvent les pigeons
citadins sur de mauvaise pente
you bet
non non c'est une dette qui les disent
nous on me dit que c'est une belle salle
de petit pas qu'est ce que tu en penses
un kangourou m6 comme fracture ne gâchez
pas vos vacances en faisant gâchis du
plâtre aujourd'hui vous avez presque
deux fois moins de risques d'avoir un
accident qu'il y a dix ans un accident
pour 2500 remontées mécaniques mais à
dio vieille fracture tibia péroné
attention je sais ce que vous avez
remarqué docteur une évolution des
accidents dus aux modifications de
chaussures
oui c'est certainement une à disons que
les problèmes et quelques chaussures
notamment chaussures de cuir qui ça a
été très près des maillots ce qu'on
appelle les chevilles en général de
données lorsqu'il avait fracturé
malheureusement une facture qui était
située très près des âmes interline
c'est-à-dire très près des articulations
ce que les entre la jambe et le pied
maintenant avec les chaussures montantes
irak et les tiges qui montrent assez aux
verrières et les complications ne sont
pas du tout les mêmes
si un patron qui faisait qu'il valait
mieux une bonne facture qui mauvaise
entorse
cependant je crois qu'on peut un peu
corrigé le tir en disant que malgré tout
une intense bien soigné bien surveillé
est quand même beaucoup plus voulons
mieux qu'une fracture faisant candélie
au prince si votre station possède sept
boules de cristal qui enregistre
l'ensoleillement passé trois jours
consécutifs sans soleil et la station
vous offre une semaine de location
supplémentaires et comme vous serez
trois millions et demi cette année sur
les pistes
cet afflux vous oblige à respecter
certaines règles un code buysse que la
vitesse n'est pas encore limité les
contractuels sont restés sur les
trottoirs des cités n'oubliez pas que
les infractions à ce code peuvent
entraîner des accidents graves ne
stationnez pas de l'office
il faut surtout pas faire je crois que
ce que je viens de faire là pour la
caméra devons être maître de sa vitesse
le skieur qui est en aval ne voit rien
et ne voit pas le sieur que vers l'amont
alors le skieur qui en avalent a
priorité sur le skieur amont en quelque
sorte donc aux skieurs allemands de
contrôler sa vitesse et de ne pas gêner
le skieur aval s comme ski
faux rappelons aux élèves de l'école
avant grands progrès dans l'enseignement
du ski le ski évolutif own l'ancien pas
toujours les loueurs de matériels lui
sont hostiles et une partie des
moniteurs n'aime pas que leur client se
passe trop rapidement 2 il est pourtant
recommandé aux débutants et bien je vous
conseillerais de d'apprendre à skier
avec la méthode évolutive qui s'établir
à l'aide de ses skis qui sont décrits
créé cours de 1 m 35 et ensuite au fur
et à mesure de vos progrès la longueur
de ce qui augmente c'est à dire qu'une
façon sur des skis de 1 m 65 jusqu'à
arriver à une taille normale de ski
compact ou de ski de ce qu'ils ont un
tel avantage de cette méthode a
l'avantagé cette méthode c'est que le
débutant se sentent en confiance
puisqu'il a l'impression en fait de ce
qui est sûr c'est pierre qu'aucun tarif
les prix ont augmenté de 10% depuis
l'année dernière
pour ce père de famille un séjour de 12
jours avec sa femme et son enfant lui
aura coûté 1400 francs y compris la
location 700 francs mais sans le voyage
il a profité des tarifs bas saison
pendant les vacances scolaires il aurait
dépensé presque deux fois plus le
restaurant c'est trop cher et il aurait
fallu prévoir avant et c'est pas du tout
prévu puis à 3-3 moment ce serait trop
pro prochain je voulais vraiment
profiter davantage même de toutes ces
sorties qui nous sont proposés ici
seulement il ya aussi des petits
inconvénients les garderies sont
relativement chers 22 francs le matin au
22 francs l'après midi c'est quand même
très cher j'aimerais profiter du cinéma
dernière chose que je ne peux pas faire
à cause de ce petit con comme le garder
la nuit que je refusais nice et celle
bien entendu voilà c'est sur la neige
que je vous quitte le journal d'avec
côte vers 22h30 pendant le deuxième
entracte de samson et dalila l'opéra de
camille saint saëns que vous offre
antenne de ce soir bonsoir à tous